[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je sens que je vais m'en prendre
une encore
vous aussi vous avez vous avez tenté un
truc aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la fermeture 43 bravo exactement
oui bienvenue dans les 12 coups et oui
je suis avec Sébastien salut Seb comment
ça va ça va 45 ans
Limoges les moches vous connaissez les
moches
vous vouliez acheter une paire de
baskets en fait c'est pas tout à fait ça
Jean-Luc en fait racontez-nous à Limoges
de la porcelaine exactement et en fait
je me rends dans un magasin de
porcelaine qui s'appelle porce moche
pour ce moche c'est un jeu de mots
et donc je rentre et je demande donc une
tasse en porcelaine
et là vous n'avez pas me croire le
vendeur va en réserve etc il me dit
c'est bien que tu as 100 % du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dis-moi pas que c'est pas possible on va
voir Jean-Luc Reichman qui nous regarde
en plus très souvent c'est la question
en France
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
sinon j'ai une chronique
on commence comme chaque semaine
pendant les magnétos parce que c'est
comme ça que vous me payez
et on fera dans les films
c'est la force de l'esprit
normalement le mec c'est tranquille
tout le monde mais toi là mets-toi là
[Rires]
mes baskets ok chérie toi tu vas encore
plus agrandir mais non t'inquiète allez
pour 2 minutes j'arrive
de la Reda qu'est-ce qu'il fait pourquoi
vous me payez Cyril pour montrer tout ce
qui se passe pendant les pubs pendant
l'oeuvre pendant les magnétos et bien
c'est parti on commence avec la Gazette
des
et on commence tout de suite avec Cyril
qui a toujours le sens du complément
avec ses invités
[Musique]
de [ __ ] la merde sur le plateau entre
les invités les chroniqueurs et ça c'est
pas bien
moi continuez avec Benjamin qui prend la
première fois de sa carrière a fait une
bonne vanne mais dommage elle est passée
une aperçu député LR propose une loi
pour pouvoir enterrer pour pouvoir être
enterré avec son animal de compagnie toi
tu te rends avec qui toi
des infos sur l'emploi du temps de Fatou
sachez que Cyril on a peut-être un peu
plus
chroniqueurs
[Musique]
mais maintenant ne discute pas s'il te
plaît c'est mon frère tu dis oui et
demande pardon on continue avec castadis
je sais pas ce qu'il est en ce moment il
se prend pour un tapeur alors que pas du
tout mais je pense que c'est quelqu'un
alors fait partie de ces clients qu'on
ne peut pas coacher bah c'est ça
et comme les absents ont toujours tort
on va remettre une petite à Castaldi
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau
qui a déjà été contrôlé positif Benjamin
arrête un peu
[Musique]
plus de bile pour digérer et la bine
c'est pas le moine
vous connaissez tous la chanson je
t'aime à l'italienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je parle avec les mains je vais pas du
tout et je vois tout rouge quand tu
parles à quelqu'un j'adore voilà j'adore
répertoire et bien figurez-vous que
Cyril a inventé une petite variante ça
s'appelle je t'aime à la tunisienne avec
grand Deckers et j'ai l'impression qu'il
a envie de lui bouffer ses petits
falafels
au Japon
de personnes au sein de cette famille
royale avec qui ils auraient eu des
tensions à la spiritueux
[Musique]
ça veut dire comme je t'aime elle nous
montre déjà
puisque je reprends une seule de cette
phrase je le mange tellement il est venu
comme tire-fif comme type moche
regardez comme il est intelligent
non rien c'est trop cool
je te manque laisse-moi je te mange un
peu laisse-moi je te montre
une tension incroyable je me trouve
[Applaudissements]
il est beau comment y Abraham Bertrand
Deckers
une fois pour ce record magnifique 2
millions 140000 téléspectateurs hier
bravo encore une fois
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière non mais
évidemment tous les journalistes bobo
comme vous les appelez les donneurs de
leçons bah se demandent comment vous
faites pour faire des scores pareil tous
les soirs et pour pas vous mentir moi
aussi je me suis posé la question de
savoir ce qu'il y avait dans TPMP qui a
pas dans les autres émissions ça
s'appelle le pendant ce temps là on va
regarder ce qui se passe sur les autres
chaînes
on commence à 18h54 histoire télé ça
parle expo
d'art moderne de Paris qui consacre une
splendide exposition à l'artiste et
expressionniste autrichien
Oscar cocochka magnifique user 54
instant culture sur TPMP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur C8
un documentaire animalier sur National
Geographic ça donne ça
[Applaudissements]
hyperactivité les solutions on va en
parler avec notre invité sur C8
21h02 sur TV ça parle de Rampage de
chaises et on le doit à Henri-Paul mais
21h02 sur C8 ça parle enfin salut
tais-toi
[Applaudissements]
n'hésite pas sera toujours le bienvenu
ici avant droit partir bravo encore pour
ces scores avant de repartir Cyril hier
vous interrogez vos chroniqueurs sur
leur dernière embrouilles et Gilles
Verdez nous a parlé d'un petit souci qui
l'aurait eu avec un gars en trottinette
électrique c'est ça oui alors on regarde
l'extrait pour ceux qui étaient pas là
hier et on en parle juste après
ce sont les trottinettes à Paris et il y
a 15 jours à l'angle de rue aux Ours
boulevard Sébastopol comme d'habitude
elle grille le feu et là je vous jure
que j'ai failli en défoncer un papier
toi moi je suis à pied toujours donc je
traverse à chaque fois évidemment le
gars arrive et là qu'est-ce que je fais
moi boum coup d'épaule pour qu'il se
casse la gueule parce qu'il a fait bah
le gars il s'approche quoi il dit
qu'est-ce qu'elle met à toi et tout ça
j'ai l'impression que c'était pas
ou le mec il était pas balèze du tout
frère le gars il était balais c'était
genre quoi vous pouvez lui demander
c'est qu'un jour le jour sebastopold
[Rires]
que vous voulez lui casser la gueule
bien sûr oui je voulais lui casser la
gueule je le redis d'accord si vous
étiez en face de lui là vous pourriez
lui dire je vous pète la gueule mais le
gars je vous pète la gueule d'accord et
bien Cyril figurez-vous qu'à 16h il y a
3h à peine et j'ai reçu ce message sur
insta le bon les petits salut Sacha j'ai
vu hier sur TPMP Versace qui racontait
l'embrouille dans la rue avec un mec en
trottinette c'était moi force à vous et
Cyril vous rigolez tardez ouf et bien
figurez-vous que on est assez réactif
la personne est à proximité
elle est juste là on peut l'accueillir
si je reste
[Applaudissements]
la vérité c'est vrai
tu peux nous raconter une histoire la
vérité
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu as vu tu as vu quoi
tout ce qu'il a dit c'est faux qu'est-ce
qu'il s'est passé
alors ça ce qu'il a dit
quelque chose
alors il arrive en trottinette il a
failli m'écraser bah tu aurais dû
le premier erreur
dans ce jour-là il y avait pas ma fille
c'est un autre jour il y avait pas ma
fille tu as failli m'écraser je t'ai
fait voler sur parce qu'à chaque fois je
m'embrouille je t'ai fait voler sur
l'autre trottoir
[Musique]
elle était un peu déglinguée parce que
pour voir
attendez coup d'épaule là je me suis pas
le souffle ça c'est le coude les boules
c'est là et je me retourne et je vois un
gars sympathique et balaise voilà et à
ce moment-là je lui dis je te fais une
leçon de morale est-ce que je t'ai pas
fait une leçon de morale un petit peu
voilà j'ai dit la prochaine fois qui tu
es pour faire ça arrête-toi au feu rouge
et tout ça et qu'est-ce que tu as fait
après
[Rires]
il m'a couru après pour faire un selfie
c'est pas vrai ça Gilles excuse-moi et
tout ça et je vais vous dire franchement
c'est
pas parce que tu dis voilà ça veut dire
qu'il est très bien mais à vous
franchement tu veux te mettre à côté du
juste pour voir le combat
Jordy
ce jour-là tu as eu peur aujourd'hui
est-ce que je peux faire un truc
mets-toi là mets-toi devant Gilles tu
vas voir si on le voit derrière ça
[Applaudissements]
la trottinette électrique tu l'avais
loué
sur la route tranquille est-ce que c'est
très plaisir que je t'en offre une vraie
pour toi une magnifique avec plaisir
alors
vous pouvez descendre au moins deux à la
rivière
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau maintenant
sur ces baskets
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je t'offre une trottinette merci
beaucoup
c'est pour moi merci mon cœur merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
tu vois Sacha tu vois tes chaussures en
taille elle serait mieux aujourd'hui
proportionnés